una campaña presidencial cada día viene
con su cuota de promesas este miércoles
fue sobre la agricultura la francia
actual que anteriormente fue una nación
el líder en el sector ya no es un lugar
en el que prosperen los agricultores
fabián guste él quiere cambiar todo eso
y asegurarse de que el país tenga al
menos a medio millón de agricultores
su oración post creo que lo mínimo que
podemos hacer para responder al desafío
alimentario y al desafío agroecológico
esto implica incluir entre 20.000 y
25.000 agricultores al año lo que supone
un esfuerzo gigantesco cuando eso lo
estamos incluyendo la mitad
los candidatos de la derecha extrema
prometieron luchar por la seguridad de
los agricultores cueste lo que cueste
la mayoría del campo es soy víctima de
una delincuencia inaceptable que es la
delincuencia itinerante a menudo de
origen extranjero itinerante
tenemos que dejar de firmar acuerdos de
libre comercio con todo el mundo es una
competencia desleal con la que es
imposible convivir la diva
el ex pastor ella en la sal se vinculó
una vez más con el público y sus luchas
los agricultores no son el enemigo y no
son los que contaminan o son los que
están calentando el planeta y al menos
no mienten como nosotros los polis no
amante para comer noble política
los mismos candidatos ya habían expuesto
su caso ante el lobby de cazadores el
presidente emacon estaba demasiado
ocupado pero al final consiguió su apoyo
los candidatos que critican a los
lobbies criticaron el movimiento
el señor strain tiene derecho a opinar
ha sido un invitado constante en el
palacio presidencial durante años el
chocante ver como los lobbies se vuelven
tan influyentes bajo el mandato de
manuel marks